[Music]
birth defects are caused by not genetics
99% of all birth defects are caused by
vitamin mineral deficiencies during
pregnancy 99% of women do not take
prenatal vitamins until they miss two or
three cycles the baby's already damaged
by them by the time they go to the
doctor to keep our kids from dying
before us you must give these young
people the 90 essential nutrients 60
minerals 16 vitamins 12 minutes of 3
fatty acids before they get pregnant
otherwise you will be burying your
children in your grandchildren James
Watson Francis Crick proposed that the
structure of DNA was the double helix
1953 1962 nine years later they got the
Nobel Prize for that in over 50 year
period 100 trillion with a T 100
trillion dollars was spent looking for
prevention and cures for genetic
diseases they never found any because
there are no Jake diseases sickle cell
anemia occurs in black people white
people Latinos red people yellow people
hummingbirds
flamingos giraffe ramps all animals all
people all vertebrates get sickle cell
anemia is not a genetic disease of black
people it's not a genetic disease it's a
birth defect mom is missing a nutrient
when the bone marrow cells are farming
in the embryo in pregnancy and so when
the baby's born it only produces
dysfunctional red blood cells